all of the little details you see on
each of the transformers had to live
somewhere inside of the car that looks
so real this is a perfect handheld
motion perfect motion blur
the thing that's struggling most here
isn't necessarily the visual effects
it's the filming
dude the more we watch this the better
it gets
it's it's so dumb wow
thanks to bessie for sponsoring this
episode stick around to the end so you
can find out how to get 25 off of each
pair of vessies
hey how's it going welcome back to
another episode of visual effects
artists react i'm joined on the couch
here by nico and sam we got some clips
we're going to be looking at today i
really wanted to look at some
transformer stuff but nico you wanted to
look at a specific shot from a more
recent film is that one clip from black
widow it's about time we looked at it i
think it's time it's been requested a
lot we strongly believe on this show
that there is value to be gained from
academically criticizing the work of
others and how can you make it better
let's jump in
don't do it
this was fun so everyone's on a green
screen that's fine
boom
little smoke trail coming off her feet
yeah it's really subtle you know what
i'll be honest
not that bad it's really not that bad
this shot that everyone's talking about
really isn't the bad shot in this scene
it's the green screen stuff right before
it happens that is jarring to me the
thing that is bugging me most about this
shot is that there's like a super
unnecessary amount of darkness
right over her face why is that not
working
it's like they specifically darkened her
silhouette it's like an anti-vignette
what we're dealing with here is a
situation where somebody was given
footage of this actress clearly filmed
indoors and then it's like okay and
she's going into a scene where it's
bright and sunny in the arctic you can
be the best vfx artist in the world but
you're dealing with here's a picture of
somebody not taken outdoors and you have
a background just outdoors you need to
bring them together somehow where is she
looking she's not looking at scarlett
johansson dude she's looking at my knees
right now she's literally just looking
below the camera yeah it kind of feels
like a reshoot kind of uh a situation
where it's like hey this isn't part of
the main production here it's like hey
florence
[Music]
whatever her name is we need you for
like a half hour we're gonna have you
like through the self-sacrifice thing so
we're gonna do these two shots of you
yelling and then we're going to yank you
on a wire i mean it's not a reshoot it
just they clearly had to pick it up
quick they didn't worry about matching
the lighting in the environment they
didn't worry about eye lines to the same
degree they're setting themselves up for
challenges because their hair is blowing
in the wind which just gets really hard
to key so i think what you're saying
nico is that the thing that's struggling
most here isn't necessarily the visual
effects it's the filmmaking i think it's
also very important to note that this
was essentially a coveted movie a lot of
this movie was created after lockdown
happened and so that introduced a whole
host of problems that we never really
get to see in the final product you know
they probably had a skeleton crew in
order to shoot these sequences here and
ironically what would have fixed this if
they just decided to shoot this outside
what would you guys do to try to make
the shot look right i mean i think the
biggest thing here is that there's like
this weird balance between the
brightness and the darkness so right
away i would just put a lot more heavy
moving smoke behind her and less in
front of her and maybe if i was actually
filming the shot put her eyeline a
little bit more to the side
so you can put anything you want in the
background maybe don't start with a hot
white cloud maybe just put a bunch of
thick smoke behind her so it justifies
her being dark and then throw a bunch of
like embers in front of the camera so
you got these little like dudes hot
sparks flying across i mean i think
there are some it could use a lot more
like particulates in the air yeah i
think this movie got a lot more hate on
the visual effects than it deserved
certainly but that scene maybe those
shots in particular deserved it
this is a pretty beefy clip here
anything that involves 80s george lucas
or steven spielberg or ilm you know
there's like a deep dive and this is
just one scene from the temple of doom i
wanted to point out this one because
every wide shot we can see of an
environment
is a miniature
how they got some of these shots i don't
know it looks they look so good like oh
you must have just built
tracks and carts and had them go on
we're seeing shots of tracks and carts
going right yeah like look that's that's
real there's no compositing happening
there
that's okay oh that okay there's
something going on there i mean
obviously i like some matted edges there
but like it might have been blue screen
yeah right there that's gabby blue
screen because you look at the lighting
on her hair oh yeah you can see the blue
spill in her hair her hair has like a
little bit of like blue tinging to it so
i guess i'm still just not understanding
what exactly is miniature here let's
just go with her i'll just say miniature
miniature miniature stop motion that's
stop motion yes i buy that for the whole
environment yeah i'm looking at real
people in those mine carts wait wait
let's see the slideshow again was that
dolls
boom yes dolls
dolls wow those are dolls
whoa i know right whoa i couldn't tell
in the first one but now that i'm
looking at it pause it's like very
clearly dolls i can't help but notice
they have fantastic motion blur on the
shot so i was noticing that too so is
that more of that sort of like it's
gotta be good smearing go motion stuff
it's gotta be just so we're on the same
page just go motion the idea of like you
have everything moving while you take
your exposure yeah you set up everything
and then like you have the camera and
whatever is going to move move when you
hit the shutter so it's like click so
yeah this is go motion but now you're
having dolls animated in stop motion at
the same time the go motions happening
every technique under the sun is used in
the scene so they do a really good job
blending like all these different
techniques together because we have our
live action plates here we have this
here that looks so real it's like
perfect handheld motion perfect motion
blur that's what's blowing my mind is
that they managed to actually replicate
this sort of like realistic camera
motion this camera shake on top of
everything being stop motion the cameras
are mounted onto motorized heads so they
are able to program in like tilts and
moves as things are happening one thing
you'll notice is that in real shots they
have torches burning and they have like
actual defined smoke with like curls
yeah and they don't have any of those in
the miniature shots which is to say in
miniature all the scale would be wonky
if you wanted to have torches in a
miniature scene they'd literally be like
little candles
some of the blue screen shots look like
rear projection to me this couldn't
match the lighting so well back in the
day if you did blue screen or green
screen like it was a big deal everybody
comes out and they work just to get two
shots for the entire day these days a
lot of green screens like throw it up
record done okay moving on yeah black
widow style black widow style so if you
guys have already seen the movie
everything everywhere all at once that
kid is the dad short round short round
okie dokie doctor
potato
[Music]
hey
we're youtubers you know what that means
it means it's time time to subscribe
first
[Applause]
this is the first transformers movie it
came out in 2007 and this particular
sequence i was in love with when we
talked about the first transformers
movie last time it was like the fifth
episode in this whole series and we were
kind of mostly just talking about the
rendering how they finally figured out
global illumination and using hdris and
proper like light values and all that
stuff but we didn't really talk about
one of the very important things of the
scene which is the animation these are
robots that are transforming not
morphing
their primary goal was to make sure that
there was no change in scale you
couldn't like grow so that meant that
all of the little details you see on
each of the transformers had to live
somewhere inside of the car they always
have some sort of like way to fold
together and then hide inside of the car
now the biggest difference between the
first movie and the second is that the
first movie they allowed those pieces to
kind of clip into each other a little
bit behind the scenes on subsequent
movies they made more of an effort to
make sure that every piece had a actual
individual like volume that could sit
inside with the car
that's a great transition of like a real
truck to the cg transformation or wait
was that a cg truck the whole time i
think this is a real truck for the
majority of the shot like i'm pretty
sure that whole rear side panel of the
truck is fake and then the front was
fake for the majority of the time we saw
it oh actually that's a half and half
shot that's like a half 3d half comp
shot yeah like look at the headlight
look at that flawless like sun glint
coming off of it and then it moves out
i'm pretty sure that's a 2d track or
where they're just taking part of the
truck oh interesting and attaching it to
the 3d animation like a little bit of
like projection yes part of the shell so
that way it's like this weird hybrid one
more thing i wanted to point out about
this truckee shot look at the shadow on
her face
she's in sunlight
and now she's in shadow
and then
back to sunlight that is a real shadow
it's gotta be which means that they had
to very precisely have a flag go out and
come back it's like so simple but it
really blends it but it's also in slow
motion that's a very fast camera move
and they just knew going into this shot
that you know the camera is pointing
upwards there's a transformer flipping
over her it's going to be casting a
shadow on her i think i put my finger on
it for why these transformers one shots
have so much impact and that's because
they're really using a lot of the guides
from like animation where it's like you
know setup and payoff and squash and
stretch and anticipation and like all
those things that make an animation feel
satisfying when you see it they're
putting into you like here when star
screams takes off like you know the
camera goes up and it's ah
you know what's that rubber band stretch
and then yes right and if you go to like
that shot of like all the transformers
fighting that town transformers five
it's just like orbit shot yeah
the drone pilot is like what's the shot
it's just kind of you know noodle around
up there
yeah it's like orbit shot the guy
literally rolls over and then floats
away
he like rolls up on the building and
then
yeah there's no like squat jets turn on
shockwave boom takes off roop collapse
and it's like
so the second movie i think suffered the
most from the whole endoskeleton problem
you couldn't tell at all who was
fighting who yeah but this scene right
here was incredible
this was an imax scene they shot this in
imax and i remember just seeing freaking
optimus wielding full-on trees it's
funny like because you're right this
seems really cool but in imax when
you're on the giant screen the handheld
camera shakes became way too hard to
track because you're looking at like 40
feet swoops from one side of the screen
to the other it's like
i remember seeing it in theaters in imax
and i was just like i'm like in a giant
earthquake sphere right now and i it was
really difficult to comprehend the scene
if you're going to make a movie in imax
you should probably like have an imac
size screening room where you're like
reviewing stuff constantly
wait go go back to your t-shirts here's
a guy's face apart it's like a weird low
quality like smoke puff like
the frame rate doesn't match you can't
mind me that might be the youtube thing
no that's those are mistimed elements
right there that's so blatant i'm pretty
sure that's the youtube rip no but
everything else is moving just fine no
it's not you can there's a frame rates
that are on the entire shot no the frame
rate stutter on the on the smoke puff
yeah it's different than the movement of
the rest of the way because they're
suffering most from the interpolation
just type in uh forest fight
transformers forest fight and let's see
if that exists
i think that's a janky element that's
been retimed all right let's find out
let's see that little smoke puff what
we're seeing is this weird interpolation
thing happening
what is that like a smoke or a 16 but
they didn't match the frame rate of
their smoke pot i don't think we can
barely like view this if you're watching
on youtube all right time to buy the
movie is that like a wilhelm scream kind
of thing so the effects artist was like
i'm gonna sneak it in we're actually
going through with this we're gonna yeah
yeah this is hilarious
it's real
it's real maybe i'm just in denial
look at that yeah i know
it's really
that's why i was like there's no way
everything else in this shot is amazing
this is not like a nitpick like i think
we both saw it like immediately we all
saw it we
saw it definitely we all sat like on the
very first viewing of that shot we just
discovered a wonky in-your-face effects
thing on top of like million dollar
footage this feels like somebody else
going into ilm shot being like it's
missing something everything else is
like the most expensive stuff and then
i'm seeing like like a 99 cent after
effects
after effects mistake president is like
my my my nephew is coming in look you
guys have to let him do at least one
thing he really wants to use your
computers sir how do you make things
slow motion in this program
you just add frames to it right
we literally just bought this movie on
amazon prime to see for certain if that
was legit and it was legit freaking
sports
dude the more we watch this the better
it gets
it's it's so dumb wow oh boy we talked a
lot about transformers today if you want
to hear us talk more about it well we
talked about it a lot and it's on the
extended episode on our website
quarterdigital.com and get a free trial
check it out tomorrow is a really really
cool corridor crew episode we visited
adam savage and he gave us a tour of his
whole cave and showed us all of the
really cool movie props that he's
fabricated over the years he has so much
cool stuff that he has made and
accumulated over the years it was
honestly just an awesome excuse to hang
out and geek out about cool stuff
consider subscribing so that you don't
miss out
okay
i heard that jordan is uh saying yes to
bessie courtesy of today's sponsor
bessie and i just i really care about
these integrations and i want to make
sure that they're in good hands
hey jordan
huh hey jay welcome back listen i i know
that you've been doing a great job with
the yessie divesti thing and people have
been liking it but i just got to know
you know if you're saying yes to vessy
you got to pass the vesti testes so i
just want to make sure you know what
you're saying about bessie jesse
say no lucky so say you got your besties
on right and you're in the rain and it's
getting kind of messy what do you do
well i just take them off and go rinse
them in the tubby they're waterproof and
your socks will still be dry oh yeah
absolutely are you just now finding out
about vessies
no
in fact i know of a secret patented
material that besties have in them and i
bet you can't tell you're talking about
dymatex diamontex is a patented material
that keeps you warm in the winter and
cool in the summer how did you know
about this that's why i wear them all
the time work out in them i wear them in
those socks because they have an
anti-bacterial soul working out and then
no socks and they don't smell you don't
know about that either
man okay are you sure that somebody like
me could say yesi to bessie oh
absolutely as long as you're okay with a
shoe that's 100 vegan and sustainably
made come on just say it with me yes see
wait yesi to vet
[Laughter]
do you think jordan passed investi
testing i think she passed the bestie
tessie and you know what i need to pause
this go to bessie.com corridor crew call
me micro managerial but i don't think
that's necessary anymore you know i
don't think i don't think i'm needed
here so i will say i am who i am in the
experience because i've learned from the
best really so yeah
that's so nice jordan
do the honors all right well you know
what just go to bessie.com crew the link
is right below so you can get 25 off of
each pair of vessies and don't forget
always say yesi to bessie
it takes a lot of time to figure out the
best clips to watch there's so many
clips out there and we don't have the
time to do research and figure this out
let us know in the comments what we
should take a look at it could be bad it
could be great it could be anything in
between let us know it's such a treat
when we're watching these clips and we
actually discover like a really janky
element that we can just sink our teeth
into
i'm so sorry for her we did that um but
you're bringing us so much joy you know
really what is the purpose of art
anyways
consider subscribing i'll see you guys
uh in our video tomorrow